we are told suppose we multiply a
complex number z
by negative one minus i so this is z
right over here
which point represents the product of z
and negative one minus i pause this
video and see if you can figure that out
all right now let's work through this
together
so the way i think about this is
when you multiply by a complex number
you are going to rotate by the argument
of that complex number and you're going
to scale the modulus of z
by the modulus of this complex number
now let me just think about that a
little bit so i'm going to draw another
complex plane here
and so this is my real axis
this is
my imaginary axis right over here
and negative 1 minus i so that's
negative 1
and then minus 1 i so it would go right
over there it would be that right over
here
and so let's think about two things
let's think about what its argument is
and let's think about what its modulus
is
so its argument is going to be this
angle
right over here and you might already
recognize that if this has a length of
one if this has a length of one or
another way of thinking about this has a
length of one this is a 45 45 90
triangle so this is 45 degrees but then
of course you have this 180 before that
so that's going to be 180 plus 45 is a
225
degree argument
so the argument here
is going to be equal to
225 degrees
so when you multiply by this you are
going to rotate by 225 degrees so let's
see this is going to be rotating by 180
degrees and then another 45. so if you
just rotated by that you would end up
right over here
now we also are going to scale the
modulus and you can see two choices that
scale that modulus and so we know it's
going to be choice a or choice b because
choices c or d you'd have to rotate more
to get over there
and so to think about that we have to
just think about the modulus of negative
1 minus i this point right over here and
then just scale up these modulus by that
same amount
well the modulus is just the distance
from 0 in the complex plane so it's
going to be this distance right over
here and you could use the pythagorean
theorem to know that this squared if you
call this c c squared is equal to 1
squared plus 1 squared or c squared is
equal to 2 or c is equal to the square
root of 2. so that's the modulus right
over here
modulus
is equal to square root of 2 which is
approximately it's a little bit more
than 1.4 so let's just call it
approximately 1.4
so not only going to rotate by 225
degrees we're going to scale the modulus
the distance from the origin by 1.4 so
if it is it looks like it's three units
from the origin right over here if you
multiply that by one point four three
times one point four is about four or it
is exactly four point two
so four point two of these units is one
two three four a little bit further you
get right over here to choice b and
we're done